midsummer is one of the most unique and
terrifying movies in recent memory and
fans have noticed some interesting
details since its release
if you're brave enough to watch the
frightening flick a second time you
should definitely keep an eye out for
these moments
before the film begins we see a colorful
folksy tapestry covered with intricate
designs
sure it looks creepy at first glance but
it's easy to assume that this was simply
included to set the mood for the movie
however if you happen to pause the film
and closely examine the tapestry
you'd find that it reveals many
important events to come
in fact much of midsummer's narrative is
illustrated on this incredibly eerie
tapestry
on the left you can see the bodies of
dany's parents and sister connected by a
tube
with a skull looming above them
representing their deaths
next up a grieving woman and her partner
walk with a group of friends to an
idyllic community where they're greeted
by a crowd of villagers all dressed in
white
finally there's the dance around the
maypole complete with a few skeletons
among the dancers
and the subsequent banquet you can even
spot pel
spying on danny and christian from his
vantage point two people dressed in
white
diving off a cliff and a bear near the
entrance to the village in other words
midsummer basically spoiled its own plot
twists but you wouldn't know it unless
you watched the film
twice even though their deaths are
integral to the plot
we only see dany's parents for a brief
moment in the film
when dany calls them worried about her
sister they're shown sleeping in their
bed
on their dresser you can see a photo of
dany which just happens to be surrounded
by flowers
upon a second viewing this instantly
calls to mind the later scenes of dany
wearing a flower crown after becoming
the may queen
some fans have theorized that the
flowers actually indicate that pell is
responsible for the death of dany's
family and he orchestrated the entire
tragedy just to lure danny into the cult
but writer director ari astor says that
this explanation doesn't hold up
telling the huffington post i can go as
far as to say that it's totally
incorrect he is not responsible
however he did state that the flowers
were an important symbol
explaining it was our way of weaving in
the idea that whatever is inevitable
is bound to happen although danny's
parents barely appear in midsummer
there's a brilliant little detail
included in the moment where we see the
doomed couple in bed
hello you have reached the ardor
residence
when their answering machine picks up
danny's call you can hear their recorded
message state that their last name is
arder
why is this significant as it turns out
the latin word arter loosely translates
to heat or to
burn not only are danny's travel
companions burned in the sacrificial
fire in the final scenes of the film
this fire also represents a sort of
spiritual rebirth for dany
whether she descends into madness or
finally experiences true catharsis
after grieving there's no denying that
by the end she has gone through a
dramatic change
it seems like astor chose this
particular name to emphasize that dany's
path has been set from the start
in some sense even before she met pel
and went to sweden it seems that danny
was always destined to be the may queen
and join the hauraga
despite the flames it's chilling to
think about
while watching midsummer for the first
time it's easy to blink and miss
all of the clues and symbols hidden
within the background artwork
but upon your second viewing look
closely when it comes to ari astor's
sets there are no accidents and all of
the artwork reveals hidden details about
the horror that's going to unfold
after witnessing what happened to dany's
family we see how her life plays out in
the aftermath
she spends much of her time isolated and
sleeping in her apartment
in one scene she's shown napping on her
couch right underneath a painting that
actually gives us a peek at what's
coming later
in the painting a girl wearing a crown
is kissing a brown bear on the nose
this symbolizes danny and christian's
relationship and if you've already seen
christian meet his end in the bear suit
there's no question as to why this
painting was chosen
and similar imagery warns christian of
what's ahead for him shortly before he
is sacrificed
while he's sitting in siv's house he's
staring directly at an image of a bear
on fire
when dany's friends are killed by the
haurga their bodies are stuffed and
dressed like scarecrows before they're
burned
it's an unsettling sight but even in the
early scenes of the film there are a few
very subtle hints that point toward
these events
for example when danny and christian are
hanging out with christian's friends
before their trip to sweden
a framed photo of the scarecrow from the
wizard of oz is visible
on top of a refrigerator in the
apartment there's also a stuffed
scarecrow doll sitting on top of a shelf
speaking with vulture writer director
ari astor said that his film was quote
the wizard of oz for perverts and during
a conversation with the nerdist the
director said that he noticed mostly in
retrospect quite a few parallels between
his movie
and the judy garland classic both are
stories of young women who travel to a
strange new world along with several
bumbling sidekicks and find themselves
during the journey
plus the color scheme even changes when
dany shows up in sweden
switching from darker tones to much
brighter hues
when dany expresses her distress over
watching the gruesome etestupa ceremony
and begins packing up to leave
pel steps in and tells her that he
understands why it was so upsetting for
her
he reveals that he also struggled with
grief after his parents died in a fire
the first time you see midsummer it's
easy to assume that pell does genuinely
relate to what dany's going through
clearly he lost his parents in a tragic
accident too and he's just trying to
empathize with her right
but when you watch this particular
conversation with the knowledge of the
hourga's traditions of fiery human
sacrifices it opens up new possibilities
was pell telling a half-truth when he
talked to danny about his past
perhaps his parents really did die in a
fire but what if their death was part of
a sacrificial ceremony like the one we
saw in the film
alternatively pell could have been
bluffing about his family history
entirely
after all he clearly knew what the rest
of his community had in store for his
friends and he was obviously attracted
to dany
maybe he was trying to exploit her
vulnerabilities and convince her that
she could trust him
either way the conversation takes on a
whole new tone
not long after arriving at the village
dany and her friends watch the hourga
children play a game they're unfamiliar
with
when they ask pell he tells them that
the game is called skin the fool
their friend simon jokes that it sounds
precious and the moment
is quickly forgotten it isn't until
later that we realize the significance
of this line
mark one of christian's friends doesn't
come across as particularly bright and
he's often the butt of the joke
it's no surprise that he's the first of
the group to disappear and for a while
viewers are left wondering what happened
to him it all makes sense when josh
sneaks out in the middle of the night to
secretly read the ruby rotter one of the
howard's sacred texts
he's shocked when mark shows up too but
upon closer inspection he realizes that
it's not mark at all
it's a villager by the name of ulf
wearing mark's face as a mask
as it turns out skin the fool wasn't
just a children's game
before committing suicide dany's sister
sends her a message saying that
everything feels
black she felt like there was no way out
from her suffering and upon her death
that suffering becomes dany's burden to
carry
and no matter how far she runs dany
cannot escape the tragedy that befell
her family
but there's an interesting call back to
this line just before the may queen
dance kicks off
when irma announces the beginning of the
dance and explains the purpose of the
tradition
she states that it's performed in
defiance of the black one
which is likely some sort of evil spirit
that the haruka believe in
he lives
down dany appears liberated as she
dances and she's embraced by the hourgla
women
dancing doesn't free her from her grief
entirely but for a while she's
completely absorbed in the competition
perhaps this is the first time that
she's able to forget the darkness that
has engulfed her if only for a little
while
throughout much of the film the
characters are under the influence of
some serious psychedelic drugs which
makes for some interesting visuals
the walls bend and waver the ground
breathes and the grass grows through
dany's feet
and sometimes unwelcome visitors show up
after arriving at the festival and
taking shrooms dany looks into a mirror
and sees her sister's face lurking
behind her and it's not the last time
that her sister's ghost makes an
appearance in sweden when she's
hallucinating
after the may queen dance dany is the
last woman standing and she's welcomed
into the fold
however she's still haunted by the
tragedy that befell her family and the
visuals indicate that her grief lingers
on
at this moment all eyes are on dany in
the procession behind her
so it's all too easy to miss what's
going on in the background
but if you look past the procession of
the harga and into the woods you'll see
the face of dany's sister
clearly visible among the trees
while the american and british
characters talk to each other in english
the hauraga mainly speaks swedish
throughout the film
after all among dany and her friends
except for pel
no one knows a word of swedish and there
are plenty of times when conversations
take place that they simply can't
understand
while bonding with the hourgla women
during the may queen dance it seems like
dany might magically
attain command of the jarga's language
but this moment is fleeting
but the swedish conversations are rarely
subtitled for the benefit of the
audience
on your first viewing you may not have
realized just how much swedish dialogue
is never translated
but when you see the film again it
becomes obvious that this was a
purposeful choice on behalf of the
filmmaker
intended to create a feeling of
isolation in the viewer
the characters don't know what the
hauraga are saying but as the audience
we're not
in on the secret either we're just as
confused and alone in this strange new
community as dany and her friends
it can be difficult to accurately
perceive the passage of time in
mid-summer
the fact that nearly the entire film
takes place in sunlight makes it hard to
keep track of how
long the group actually stays with the
harga but remember the festival is
supposed to last for nine days
and although the days seemed to blend
into one another astor confirmed to
digital spy that the human sacrifice
doesn't mark the end of the midsummer
festival in fact he's stated that there
are still
several more days of celebrations to
come on your second viewing of the film
you might find it easier to separate
when one day ends and the next begins
which opens up new questions about what
happens after midsummer's fiery ending
who knows what kinds of festivities are
in store for dany will she find a home
with the hourga for the rest of her life
or is she still in danger check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one